- I…am inevitable.
- I…am Tractorcito.
- Let me know....
if you need a quarterback next year.
- Hello, Derrick.
- Ya, I think I’ll go to space for a little bit.
- OK, SO I GUESS I’M LIKE THE MAIN GUY GOING FORWARD.
Now that Brady has been defeated,
the AFC has…
...returned after a four-year absence.
- I DON’T CARE IF HE GOT DEFEATED.,
NO ONE CAN TAKE AWAY HIS SIX STONES.
- TEAM TRIP TO MIAMI, BRO.
THINK OF ALL THE BESPOKE SUITS I GET TO WEAR.
- I just hope I find the courage to tell the football how I feel….
- YOU MIKE THAT?!
- OW, OW, OW.
- Nice try, Alex Smith.
- THERE’S A HOT GUY UNDER THAT HELMET!
- Patrick, this is Mysterioppolo.
- Hey, kid, I think it’s real cute when you run around and s--t.
- Without the threat of Patriots,
his dimension, the NFC, has grown new monsters every year.
- Wow, I bet he never hurts his knee and misses games…
YOU SHOULD BE AMERICA’S FAVORITE.
- YO, NERDS,
THE KID HAD NO IDEA I’M JUST FOLLOWING KYLE’S SYSTEM!
- WOO, SPLIT CARRIES!!!
- Now that we have the lead, just run it.
- We see you watching the episode,
just wanted to mention State Farm.
- Can I finish it?
OK, yeah. It's legendary!
- I’ve been meaning to tell you something…
What, no, I’m not Scramble-Man.
Who told you that?!
- Jimmy...the Niners...the—
- DATA-DRIVEN FURBALL?!
THIS IS WORSE THAN WHEN I GOT STUCK IN THE SCRAMBLE-VERSE.
- YOU ALL TAUGHT ME…
THAT IT’S DOPE TO SCRAMBLE.
- Hello, I’m…uh….
- JIMMY GAROPPOLO.
- JIMMY Garage-oh-no.
- Hey, that hairy frog child is back, baby.
- Activate defense, Saleh.
- WOOO, I’M TOO SPICY FOR THE BROWNS.
- BOSAAAAA.
- NOOOO-SAAAA.
- Y'ALL SORRY-ASS RECEIVERS DON’T KNOW ME.
- I had a bye week to plan for everything.
- @BBQLUVER, LET ME TELL YOU WHY YOU’RE WRONG
IN 30 TWEETS.
- I DON’T WANT TO DIE! HONEY BADGER DO GIVE A F--K!
- I GOT THIS.
- WOOOO! CAN YOU SMELL WHAT THE NEW GRONK IS COOKING?
- With our schemes, we can make you see anything.
- I, uh, think I did the time thing again.
- AHHHH!
- Patrick, I'm…I’m leaving you.
- THIS CAN'T BE REAL.
NO-LOOK THROW!
- NOOOO! HE BENT MY FLAT BRIM.
- So then pew pew, Pat will hit back here
- But then what’s this? BABAM, Kittle has a bomb!
- THANKS, TEACH.
- Yeah, got it, whatever.
- Subscribe to this channel.